I am thrilled to see so many people here
on a Thursday evening.
And I actually, just so that we can
understand our marketing efforts a little
bit better, I would love to know, just a
show of hands, Stanford GSB students.
If I could see where the GSB students are?
Excellent, excellent.
Greetings in the balcony.
Stanford undergrad students, welcome.
We love having you here.
Members of the rest of the Stanford
community, faculty, staff, alumni, that
sort of thing.
And from the Harvard community, who has
joined us besides our speaker?
Welcome.
We are delighted that you are here.
Tonight is a chance for two great schools
to come together.
And, we are delighted for the evening,
that we are going to spend with you.
My name is J.D. Schraum.
I'm a faculty member here at the GSB.
I teach courses in Communication, and I
also
have the privilege of leading the
Mastering Communication Initiative.
Which is is a series of non-credit
offerings to help
students build their abilities to speak,
write, and participate more effectively.
Behind me you will see some of the events
that are coming up through the rest of
quarter.
If you don't have the moment to write them
down quickly, you can go to our
website, which is simply
gsb.stanford.edu\mastery, and that will
open up the world of mastering
communication to you.
When we were looking for a speaker for
this evening, we really wanted to
find somebody who had made their success
because of their ability to communicate
effectively.
And, last year I had the privilege of
seeing Salcon at the TED Conference.
Saw him speak at a company here in the Bay
area, and we began our dialog to have him
come in.
Before I introduce the student who will
introduce Sal to you, there's one
event in particular that I wanna be sure
that I mention to you.
And that is, that we have a viewing of the
TED Conference this year.
It will happen from February 28th to March
2nd, and we have
a site license, to broadcast the full TED
Conference, here to the GSB.
To our GSB students, I encourage you to
sign up by going to our website.
You'll also see information about it, in
the
distributions that come out to you,
through email.
But that is, we're excited about having
that event here.
You did not come here tonight to hear from
a professor.
You came to hear from an entrepreneur.
And so to introduce him, I'm delighted to
welcome to the stage Luke Pena.
Luke is a second year MBA student in the
joint degree
program, between the School of Ed and the
School of Business.
And Luke, if you could come forward.
>> [SOUND].
>> From age eight to age 13, my home was
my classroom.
And I was my own teacher.
Now I have the privilege of standing
before
you as Luke Pena, joint MBA MA Education
degree
student, Co-President of the Stanford
Education Club, and proof
that non-traditional students can find the
path to success.
It's my great honor and privilege to
welcome you all here tonight.
And my responsibility to remind you to
please not
use your cell phones and computers during
tonight's event.
Back to the classroom of my youth.
I was a hyperactive child with a
hyperactive mind.
Traditional schools evaluated me and
determined that I
would require either medication, or
special education courses.
My mother disagreed.
So my mother decided to homeschool me, and
serving as my teacher through the fifth
grade.
I took tests every year to make sure that
I was performing
at or above the level of my peer group in
traditional schools.
When my mother decided to return to
undergraduate school
to pursue her degree, I became my own
teacher.
And for the next five years I relied on
a variety of non-traditional education
resources to guide my learning.
Without access to these resources, I would
never have found my own passion for
education.
I would have never survived grade school,
and I
would never have found my way here to
Stanford.
I know that there are countless
other students, traditional and
non-traditional, who require
and desire and desperately need these
innovative
resources to create their own education
opportunities.
Khan Academy is creating these very
opportunities for students around the
globe.
Along the way, Khan Academy is redefining
the very
way we think about teaching, about
learning, and about education.
The organization is committed to changing
education for the
better by providing a free, world-class
education anywhere, anytime.
The Khan Academy website now provides
self-pacing
software and includes over 3,000
instructional videos
on its YouTube channel, covering
everything from
basic arithmetic to college-level science
and economics.
It's the most used library of educational
videos on the web with 3.7 million
unique students per month, over 88 million
lessons delivered, and over 260 million
exercises completed.
A growing number of classrooms around the
world are relying on Khan Academy to
build student mastery of topics, and to
create space in class for dynamic,
project-based learning.
Khan Academy owes its success to its
founder Salman Khan.
Khan was helping a young cousin with math
in
2004, communicating by phone and using an
interactive notepad.
When others expressed interest, he began
posting his
hand-scribbled tutorials on YouTube, and
demand took off.
Before founding Khan Academy, he was the
portfolio manager at
Khan Capital Management, and the Senior
Analyst at Wall Capital Management.
Sal received his MBA from Harvard Business
School,
where he was president of the student
body.
He also holds a Masters in electrical
engineering
and computer science, a BS in electrical
engineering and
computer science, and a BS in mathematics
from MIT,
where he was president of the class of
1998.
While at MIT, Sal was the recipient of the
[UNKNOWN] Fellowship,
which he used to develop web-based math
software for children with ADHD.
Children not unlike myself.
Ladies and gentlemen, please join me in
welcoming Sal Khan.
>> [SOUND].
>> Thank you much.
This is very exciting.
So, so how many of ya'll have been to the
site, or used the site and, in some way?
Oh good.
So this is a good, good, good audience.
So I guess, how many of you have not been
to the site?
Oh good, so, so I have something to show
you.
So for those of you that have not been to
the site,
I have a little montage that shows what,
what the videos look like.
But what we'll see over the course of
this, and I
actually do wanna make it as much of a
conversation as possible.
There's microphones and all the rest.
I'm gonna talk for, I don't know, ten or
15 minutes.
And then I just wanna have questions,
comments, anything else.
But we'll see, Khan Academy is much more
than just a library of videos that
initially I started creating, and now we
have
a few other people working on as well.
But let me just show, oh yes.
>> One moment to handle a technical issue.
>> Alright that wasn't too bad.
>> That was the pre-show music.
>> Oh, oh, okay, there's other things
happening in the background.
Okay, alright, very good.
So here we go.
>> We can integrate over the surface and
the notation usually is a capital sigma.
All these interactions are just due to
gravity
over interstellar, or almost you could
call it intergalactic.
So the right slot is i plus 1.
This animal's fossils are only found in
this area of South America.
Nice clean band here.
They create the Committee of Public
Safety,
which sounds like a very nice committee.
Notice, this is an aldehyde, and it's an
alcohol.
>> It's some type of infectious disease.
>> Exactly so the key is, when you start
to look
at data, you have to look at all aspects
of it.
>> [UNKNOWN] is their $30 million, plus
the $20 million from the American
manufacturer.
If this does not blow your mind, then you
have no emotion.
>> [LAUGH].
>> Well-educated audience.
You appreciate Euler's identity and The
French Revolution, that's very good.
So just to get you up to speed, and a
little bit of this was covered in the
introduction, and this,
this slide, and actually some of the data
from the
introduction was a few months old, and
this is old, too.
What we're actually now pushing about five
million unique students a month.
They're doing two million exercises a day,
actually, and, and, and growing.
And you know, out in Silicon Valley we get
used to a million here, million there.
Oh, you know, that's not so exciting until
you get to ten million or whatever else.
But, but in education these really are
large numbers.
And, you know, I didn't do that to pick on
Harvard,
but, but that is, and actually since these
numbers are older
now that, on a monthly basis, we're
serving six to seven
times the number of students that Harvard
has served since 1636.
And we're growing 400% a year, so it's,
you know, we'll see where that goes.
But before we go in kind of the present of
what Khan
Academy's up to, I wanna talk a little bit
about how it happened.
Cuz it's, it's, you know, I still kind of
wake up in the middle of the night
and wonder about this very strange journey
that you're
kind of catching me hopefully in the
middle of.
Or maybe very close to the beginning of,
hopefully.
It's been good so far.
As was introduced, 2004 I had just gotten
married.
I was a newly minted MBA, graduated in
2003.
Was working in Boston as an analyst at a
hedge
fund, and I had family visiting me from
New Orleans.
Right after my wedding in New Jersey, they
came up to Boston.
My 12 year old cousin, Nadia, her younger
brother,
Arman, who's two years younger and then
the youngest, Ali.
And I showed them all the sights in
Boston, and I was very impressed with
Nadia.
I hadn't seen her since I had left from,
you know, I
grew up in New Orleans where, since I was
in high school.
So, she was like two or three years old,
and now
she's 12 years old, super smart girl, and
I kept encouraging her.
I was like oh, you know, you should think
about some
of these fancy schools that are in town,
and all the rest.
And her mom told me, one morning before
Nadia had woken up, that this
is very nice, Nadia views you an older
brother figure and all the rest.
But, she's actually having trouble with
mathematics.
And, I, I, had trouble believing this.
You know this, one I, we were having
conversations and she seemed
at least you know super, she intimidated
me among half the conversations.
And on top with that you know, we shared a
certain amount of DNA.
>> [LAUGH].
And so, so I told [UNKNOWN] Nadia's
mother,
that, you know, I find that hard to
believe.
And when Nadia woke up, I said, well
what's going on?
And she said, I took a placement exam, and
I, there's unit
conversion, ounces to gallons, kilo, you
know, kilometers, meters, miles, things
like that.
And she says, I just don't get that.
I, you know, my brain just checks out.
And I told her, I was like, look Nadia,
I, I've had conversations with you last
few days.
We even did, I remember these little brain
teasers while
we were waiting for the fireworks over the
Charles River.
And I said, all of that stuff that we've
been talking
about is ten times deeper and more
conceptual than, than units.
And I, I'm not saying this just as a kind
of a pep talk.
You, you can do this.
And, and, you know, I think like a lot of,
not just
children frankly, people who've disengaged
with
some content, they appreciate the pep
talk.
But they're like oh, okay, you know,
that's nice
but, you know, it, it probably doesn't
apply to me.
And so I said, well, let's make this
happen.
You go back to New Orleans.
They, they still lived in New Orleans.
And, every day after work, I'll, we'll get
on something.
We'll get on the conference phone and will
use
Yahoo Doodle or something, and, and we'll
work together.
And, and she agreed.
I think she was skeptical, but she says,
oh, I have this cousin, kind
of an older brother figure who wants to
spend time with me, worth a try.
And long story short, you know, they went
back
to New Orleans she, she, we started
working together.
The first month was hard, but she
eventually did get past that.
And then we started just doing random
topics, algebra here
and there, and she actually became an
advanced math student.
And then I, I kind of I, I, I've
coined the phrase I became somewhat of a
tiger cousin.
>> [LAUGH].
Perhaps better than a tiger mom.
And, and I called her school and I said
she should retake the exam.
You don't understand what she's
accomplished.
There was some resistence on that part
and, and, and I'm
like oh then, you know, her mom isn't
telling me this.
It's, it's i'm telling and, and but, she
was able to take it, and
she took the exam and she ended up
becoming a very advanced math student.
She ended up taking calculus her freshman
year in high school.
She ended up taking math at University of
New Orleans through
most of high school, so she became this
really advanced math student.
That same student who thought she couldn't
get units.
But I was excited.
You know, my day job, I wasn't able to
exercise some of these, these same ideas.
So I, I I started tutoring her brothers,
things started to go well with them.
Then I would, you know, would call up
random
family members, and say, can I tutor your
kids?
[LAUGH].
>> And, there was kind of a tone like, oh,
things must not be going so well at the
hedge fund.
[LAUGH] Sal's, looking for a back up job.
Which is kind of true, I guess.
But but, but, so that's what happened.
And you fast forward to 2006 and I had a
cohort of about 15 or 18, yeah,
about 15 to 20 family, friends and
relatives
around the country that I was tutoring
after work.
And it was interesting, I mean, but it
wasn't as good
as those interactions with Nadia where it
was one on one.
I started writing a little bit of
kind of fairly primitive software
initially, so that
I could give them example problems, I
could keep track of what they were doing.
I mean, it's amazing when you, as soon as
you keep track of things and you
see the real-time data, you start saying,
why
is Ali doing problems at three in the
morning?
This is, you know, irrespective of
algebra, this is an issue.
>> [LAUGH].
>> But, but I started doing that.
And in 2006, the firm I was working
for, actually I was working at Wohl
Capital Management.
It was a, a, a two person and a dog firm.
the, the dog was our Chief Economist.
And and Dan's wife who, Dan was my boss,
his, his wife became a professor at
Stanford Law School.
And so we moved the firm out to Palo Alto,
actually it was on Menlo Park.
And and I was based out here.
And in 2006 I was having dinner in San
Mateo with a buddy from,
from college and ya know I was showing
this software that I was building.
And it gave you hints and generated
problems, and I was
telling him about all these vid, actually
I wasn't making videos yet.
I was telling him about these tutoring
sessions I was doing.
And, I told him my, my only frustration
is, is that
now when I do these sessions, I do a
session with Sasha.
I'm like, oh, I wish he was there when I
covered that
same material with Arman or with Nadia
last week or last year.
A lot of times when I, when I did these
video
tutorials, you know, I would ask them,
whoa, do you get this?
Does this make sense to you?
And there would be kind of this, pregnant
pause and they
would say, yeah, yeah, yeah, I get it, I
get it.
And you know they didn't, but you didn't
want to push the
issue and make them feel weird about it
and all the rest.
They just didn't wanna waste my time.
And you, you would have these things
happening.
There was a sense that they, they had
basic questions, but they were afraid to
ask.
You know, they forgot how to divide
decimals even though they're in ninth
grade.
And they didn't want to embarrass
themselves, because I've been telling
them that you're smart, and you can do all
of these things.
And my buddy, he told me, well, you know,
there's this thing called YouTube.
Why don't you make some tutorials on
YouTube and, and put 'em up there?
And, you know, my, my initial reaction I,
no, no, that doesn't make any sense.
YouTube is for cats playing piano.
>> [LAUGH].
It's not for, for, for serious
mathematics.
But then I went home that weekend and I,
and I, and I got over
the idea that, that it wasn't my idea,
which is hard for an MBA, sometimes.
>> [LAUGH].
[UNKNOWN] and, and, and, and I gave it a
shot and and it was funny.
You can, yeah you can look at those first
videos there that, that are
I mean literally November 2006, least
common
multiples, some basic algebra, things like
that.
And interesting things started to happen.
I, I, one, I pointed my cousins and
family friends these, these people I was
tutoring.
I pointed them to the videos, I said what
do you think of them?
And you know, I joke a lot about this if
any of ya'll
saw the TED Talk, I talk about this too,
but it was absolutely true.
The first feedback they gave me was that
they preferred me on YouTube than in
person.
[LAUGH] And I still haven't clarified how
broad of a statement that is.
If it's just math, math videos or, or not.
but, but, but that, that meant a lot and,
and, and all of these ideas of, when the
live session, being afraid to ask
questions, being afraid
to admit that you might have forgotten
something before.
Being afraid to ask this person you
respect or
this person who respects you, asking them
to repeat something.
You're afraid you're wasting them time.
Now, all of sudden, they had it all on
demand.
They can pause and repeat as much as they
want.
And they can watch it.
They can watch it when they're ready for
it.
And when, when we're doing the live
sessions, there's a
huge value there, and we'll talk about
that in the future.
We think that a lot of what were doing is
only going to enhance the live session.
I was taking interest, there was this bond
that was forming, but the
hard parts were, after work, some days I
wasn't on my A game.
I had a hard day at work or whatever.
And, and many times I could imagine Nadia
the girl, the guy
that she had a crush on asked some other
girl to the prom.
And she was just depressed, and she's not
that
interested in the least common multiple or
whatever, whatever else.
And so, that was a pretty interesting
thing,
so I just kept making more and more
videos.
my, my wife at this point was a medical
resident,
so I had a lot of time on my hands.
And, and the videos were out there.
I kept doing more and more videos.
And then, like, I guess a lot of stories
like this, I started
to realize that people that I was not
related to were watching the videos.
And you know, the initial comments were
things
like, thank you, or, or this really
helped.
And I don't know how much time you all
have spent on YouTube, but
most of the comments aren't quite
positive,
if you're, or G-rated for that matter.
But, but so just that, thank you this
helped.
But then started to get comments coming in
and, and, and as the traffic grew the
comments got more and more, we get higher
volume and we started getting really
touching comments.
My children have dyslexia, my children
have ADHD and this
is the only thing that is getting through
to them.
I got a letter early on from a, from a kid
who was about to drop out of high school
and he said, this was, these YouTube
videos were the
only thing that got him to re-engage with
the content.
Early on I got a, a letter from a parent,
saying that they're praying for me.
And, and, and, you know, I, I was an
analyst at a hedge fund.
>> [LAUGH].
This was a this was other than my
investors,
I don't think there was much prayer going
on.
so, so, so, so I just kept going.
And, and that was the other discovery that
started
to happen, is that, this wasn't, you know,
when
you look at an algebra textbook, and a
calculus
textbook, there are these thousands pages
and all that.
You immediately assume oh, there's, you
know, I can just make a dent in that.
There's no active cover.
But, you have like 70 or 80 videos, hey,
that's a pretty good scaffold of algebra.
There's now like 600 or something on the
site.
But that was a pretty good scaffold of
algebra.
Do a few more, that's a pretty good
scaffold of, of calculus.
And you start realizing that, in a lot of
the
world, people say, oh, you should focus on
platform, not content.
Content doesn't scale.
But education content really does scale.
If it's done once, it can be used forever.
Calculus isn't changing every, every three
years, as the textbook
publishers would have you believe.
>> [LAUGH].
>> so, just kept going, and by 2009,
frankly I had trouble focusing on my day
job.
And I was working at another fund out here
in Palo Alto, Connective Capital.
And so I you know that introduction, there
was
a brief moment of Khan Capital, but it
never got
beyond Khan's capital, so I kind of just,
which
wasn't significant, by the way I'm
dressed, you can tell.
But the, the so, so, I had trouble
focusing on
my day job, and so I, I kinda had a sit
down with my wife and we figured out,
well, someone's gotta
realize this is like the highest possible
social return on investment.
That just for one guy's salary or
whatever,
you can educate, at that point I think
we were getting, already we have on the
order of about a million students per
month.
Actually, no, we have several hundred
thousand students
per month, but that can only grow over
time.
And even if I got hit by a bus these
videos, in theory, could keep teaching.
And if we could build out a platform and a
virtual school, we
could reach an infinite number of students
and translate and all the rest.
And so, somewhat naively, I had already
set up Khan Academy as a not for profit
and I, I'm happy to answer any questions
about why, why we decided to do that.
But so I take the leap of faith.
I, I had no experience really starting an
not for profit,
even how do you raise money for, or any of
that.
But, it was just this idea that someone
should hopefully realize that this is
worth doing.
And so like a lot of I think
entrepreneurial
stories for profit or not for profit, you
quit.
There's always a few leads that you think,
oh
those are gonna happen next week, and then
they don't.
And, and, and, about eight months into it,
you
start getting really stressed, and, and, I
started updating my
resume and, you know, seeing if the hedge
fund
world would have me back after I
completely flaked out.
God forbid starting a not-for-profit.
And but then something interesting
happened.
I had this little link on the site, a
PayPal link.
College students around the world were,
you know,
they were giving $10, $5, which meant a
lot.
But all of a sudden a $10,000 donation
came in, over PayPal.
And so, I, I checked who it was and, and
it
was a, it was a woman by the name of Ann
Doerr.
And so I immediately emailed her back.
And she was actually, I saw the address,
she was in Palo Alto.
And I said, well, you know, thank you?
If if, if we were a physical school, you
would now have a building named after you.
>> [LAUGH].
>> If it's which is, and, and talking to
the folks here, I hear that's a very good
deal.
I don't think $10,000 quite, quite cuts
it.
>> A water fountain.
>> Maybe the podium, not even, yeah, the
water fountain.
But, so, so Ann, Ann immediately emails
back and
says, whoa, I'd, I'd be interested in
talking to you.
So we literally, we met at one of the
Indian buffets on University Ave.
And, she says, well, where are you going
with this, what do you wanna do?
And, and, and her first question actually
was, how are you supporting yourself?
And, you know, in as proud a way as
possible, I said, I'm not.
[LAUGH] And she kind of nodded and she
said, well where are you hoping to take
this?
And I had these, I had these slides, and I
said, well, we could build out
the software that I started with my
cousins,
and we could, we could reach more
students.
We could translate it, we could have
interactivity on the site.
We could do as much as possible
of creating a real virtual interactive
experience.
And, she kind of nodded.
And then, you know, I got back in my car
and, and Ann actually got on her bike.
She rode her bike to, to the buffet, which
I was very impressed.
And, and, when I was driving it to my
driveway,
I got a, I got a text message from Ann.
And, and it said, you should be supporting
yourself.
I just wired you $100,000.
so, so, so it was a good day.
>> [LAUGH].
It was, it was almost, almost, crashed
into the garage.
And as we will see in this story, Ann's
text messages are always good things.
>> [LAUGH].
>> So this wasn't, this wasn't that long
ago.
This was literally about, not even two
years ago.
This was May of 2010, and, right around
that same time, actually a few weeks
later, but these were all kind of
unrelated
events some folks at Google brought me in.
You know, I, I say, you know, there's two
major institutions in Mountain View,
Google and the Khan Academy.
>> [LAUGH].
It's they don't laugh as much.
But the, the and, they brought me in and
it was kind of mysterious meeting.
They said you know a lot of our children
are using your stuff.
We even use some of your finance stuff.
It's interesting for us.
What would you do if you had more
resources?
And I, I kinda made the same pitch.
And they all nodded and and then you know,
I kind of assumed and by
this point I had spoken to many
foundations and I'd become fairly cynical
about things.
I was like, okay, this isn't gonna work
out.
But at least Ann, I can continue to
do this and pay my mortgage and whatever
else.
And then in July of that, so this is July
of 2010, I
was running a little summer camp for, it
was actually in Portola Valley.
And I had this, you know, little game, it
was mainly for middle school students.
Six of the students were playing a game of
Risk, and then the other
20 students were trading securities based
on the outcome of the game of Risk.
And, and, and while that was happening,
literally a trading floor, it's
a very good game, actually, maybe the
business school should look into it.
But, but the, while, while that was
happening,
I, I got a text message from Ann.
And, and the text, you know, text messages
are kind of
hard to figure out which one came first,
and all the rest.
But it was like, Bill Gates, 600 people,
Aspen, talking about you.
And I was like, Ann knows people that Bill
Gates would talk about, so maybe this was,
you
know, some type of, you know, she wouldn't
have
a, she didn't seem like much of a
prankster here.
But I was like, is, you know, what's going
on here?
So I immediately, I went on to, and I
booted the nearest 7th grader off of a
computer [LAUGH].
>> [LAUGH].
>> And I said, what's going on here?
And people are already commenting, and
blogging and putting it on Twitter.
Bill Gates, in front of, using the, you
know, Aspen Ideas Festival,
and the stage, the main, whatever,
pavilion, he just started talking for ten
minutes about how he and his children were
using the Khan Academy,
and it was like the one thing that he was
most excited about.
And my brain immediately said, those
videos were
for Nadia, not for, not for Bill Gates.
>> [LAUGH].
>> This is, you know, I, I have to really
re, rethink some of those.
But, but then, and, and it was, and, and,
and,
I mean the video's actually up on our site
now.
It was very surreal, and I didn't see it
that first day.
I saw it a few days later after the video
actually got posted.
And, then I was in this very strange,
surreal
world, because this event happened some
place in reality.
But, I was like you know, what do I do
now?
Do I call him [LAUGH], you know?
>> [LAUGH].
>> Can I find his number?
I don't think so.
And, and, and, but luckily, that kind of
tension got alleviated.
About two weeks later, I got a call from,
I guess, Larry
Cohen, who was able to find my number,
Bill Gates' Chief of Staff.
And he says, you know, Bill, you probably
heard, is a big fan.
He uses your stuff.
He actually told me that Bill has three
monitors, and I've seen
it, and apparently, Khan Academy is like,
he's regularly watching videos on there.
And, and, and he's like, you know, if, if
you have time to, Bill would like to meet
you.
and, and I was looking at my, you know, I
have
my calendar open for the whole month,
right, right at that moment.
>> [LAUGH].
And it was completely blank.
And so, [LAUGH] so, I was like yeah, you
know,
maybe like next Wednesday, 2:45, I could
fly right into Seattle.
And, you know, right in between a bath
and,
you know, laundry, I can squeeze, squeeze
Bill Gates in.
And, and so, I, I flew up to Seattle, met
with Bill Gates, which was a surreal
meeting, you know?
20% of my brain was in the meeting, the
other 80% was, this is Bill Gates!
That's Bill Gates!
What would happen if I hit him?
>> [LAUGH].
What would happen if I [LAUGH] I didn't
want to but you, you can imagine.
So, so, but, but you know, I presented,
and you know, there was an awkward moment
where I had, I had these, I called them my
slide placemats, and I walked around.
And I was like, oh, you know, I use these
cause I don't trust PowerPoint.
These things are always [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGH].
>> I think he found me charming [UNKNOWN].
But, you know, long story short he, he
said, oh wow, this makes sense.
I'm a big fan, what would you do, I, I
give, we make a virtual school, and all
the rest.
And he's like no, this, this is great and
he nodded.
And when he nodded five people in the back
of the room took notes.
>> [LAUGH].
>> And I was like, make sure you got that.
And, and so it looked like things were
going good
and, and right around that same time
another meeting with Google.
Google said, well what would you do with
$2 million.
And I said, you know, is this an open
question,
because, you know, I've got needs, you
know, I could [LAUGH].
There's not a, they clarified it.
[LAUGH].
And, and, and, and, and so, I kind of, I,
I, I, I kind of made the same, the same
idea.
And so, October 2010 all of these things
converged.
The Gates Foundation funded us to really
get office space, hire up our core team.
Google funded us, translated into ten
languages, build out the
core software, and, this is what we
started to build.
And actually some of this was already you
know, the primitive version was there
before the funding
happened, but now we got essentially
competent people to
work on, to work on some of this stuff.
And this is what we call a knowledge map.
And it's constantly changing.
There's like sixty nodes right here.
It's now 300 and we're, we're exploring
different ways to visualize this right
now.
But the, but the idea is very simple.
That top, that top star there is the most
basic mathematics, level one addition.
And once you get, once you've shown
proficiency
in that, it moves you down this knowledge
map.
And right now, the bottom end of it,
you have things like calculus and, and
whatever else.
And, and actually, we can see it.
So this is one for getting the intuition
of a derivative.
Where you're trying to, do, where you take
the slope of a tangent line at any
point and you're essentially plotting out
the derivative
by picking out the slope of the tangent
line.
And so we're trying to make that knowledge
of math goes as broad and deep as
possible.
Our videos you saw, they go into things
like finance and macro and micro economics
and things, you know, [UNKNOWN] there's a
little bit of medicine and things like
that.
But right now our exercises are mostly
math, but we're hoping
to get that as, as broad and as deep as
possible.
And this right over here, is a more basic
one,
and if you ever need help, the videos are
there.
This is basic subtraction, literally and,
and, you know,
the one thing I always emphasize, I talked
a
lot about this in the TED Talk is, we
did this kinda the way is common sense,
you know?
If you learned, if you went to music
class, you won't
[UNKNOWN] a harder piece until you do,
master an easier piece.
If you're in Tae Kwon Do, you don't take
the black belt test until you're already
at a, I don't know, what is it, brown
belt, or a green belt, or whatever.
You only progress once you're ready for
it.
And that's how it works in video games and
everything else.
But that's not how it works in the
traditional academic model.
In a traditional academic model, what is
fixed is, how long
you have to learn something, and when you
have to learn something.
And what's variable is, how well you
actually learn that topic.
And in everything else, and I would say,
natural learning.
And in this, we just said, well let's do
the opposite.
Let's make variable when you learn it, and
how long you have to learn it.
And what's fixed is a high level of
mastery.
So that you can build on that foundation.
I mean, the analogy I say in, in the
traditional academic model, and it's not
picking on anyone.
It's the model that we've all been,
frankly, indoctrinated into.
Is, I'm building a house, I lay the
foundation.
I go get the inspector to come by.
And the, the, the inspector says, okay.
Yeah, this foundation's about 80%
structurally sound and I say, great.
That's passing.
Let's build the first floor.
And then they do the first floor, oh 70%.
Oh that's passing, let's build a second
floor.
And then when the fourth floor collapses
and takes the
whole thing down with it, I blame the
fourth floor contractor.
Instead of saying what what, I had these
gaps this whole time, that were just
making
my whole building less and less
structurally sound,
and that's exactly happening frankly, with
math education.
But I think probably with most forms of
education, especially
things that assume some level of mastery
of more basic ideas.
So we,we, we started up.
We got our office space, and, and
interesting, you know, and as
you can see, a lot of this stuff was
unplanned serendipitous events.
Right when we got our office space,
actually
right before we got our office space, the
Los Altos school board, right here, Los
Altos
said, hey we heard your are doing some
stuff.
Why don't you come meet us.
So we met them and they's like what would
you do.
If you could do anything you wanted with a
fifth grade class room?
And we said well we would have every
student learning at their own pace.
They would master concepts before moving
on.
And, the role of the teacher instead of
giving
this one size, one pace fits all lecture,
the
teacher would get da, data, would get
analytics so
that they can do focused one on one
interventions.
Or even better they can pair up students
with each
other so that they can teach each other
and get.
Get even deeper learning.
And kind of surprising, they two days
later said, sounds good.
Well, let's start after Thanksgiving.
And so we had to hire up a little bit.
And so, this right here is a dashboard
from that Los Altos pilot.
And we're constantly iterating and trying
to improve these things.
But the general model is, each column here
is one of those concepts on that knowledge
map.
Each row here is one of the students in
the class.
Green means, and, and actually there's a,
a fancier
version of this now, this is a few months
ago.
Green means a student's proficient in it,
blue means they're working
on it, but no need to worry, and red means
they're stuck.
So the model is, hey, instead of one size
fits all
lecture, why don't I get that, why don't I
get one
of those students who've already mastered
Exponents level 3 to tutor
this student right over here who is having
trouble with it.
And if they, if that doesn't work, then I
as a teacher can go do a.
A focused one on one intervention.
And, what's neat about it is, and
we've, we're actually seeing this in the
classroom.
Is it's optimizing the, the, the most
scarce resource in the classroom.
Which is actually the time with other
human beings.
And so now, you know, people talk about
teachers, teacher, student ratio.
What we think we're optimizing is.
The, the, the student to valuable time
with the teacher ratio.
Or even better, the student to valuable
time with
other human beings rate, ratio, because
you also have
the other, the other peers that you're
learning from
and actually, one of the pilots, it was
interesting.
The teacher spent a significant amount of
time
mentoring a, a subset of the fifth graders
STAs.
Fifth graders.
And we wanted to arm them with as much
data as possible.
And so, it should not freeze like this.
Let me see.
Well, there's a very nice chart that shows
up.
All right let's try this again.
Oh there you go.
So this tells us, a teacher what the
student's been working
on, and actually students have access to
all of these things.
And we found that the best way to teach
elementary school sti,
students to read bar graphs, is to make
the bar graphs about them.
[LAUGH].
>> We are, we are all narcissist inside,
it's the
This tells a, a student a, parent, a
teacher and all of this is free.
It's all available right now.
You can go be, and come your cousins, or
your nephews or, or coaches right now.
This tells the teacher what a student's
been focused on, videos and exercises.
You can drill down as much as you want.
This gives granular data on exactly what
problem the student did when.
Now we have features you can click on.
You can actually see the narrative of that
problem, what the
students, what choices they got wrong,
what did they get right.
What hints did they use?
And this right here is just another
dashboard for teachers, but for us, it
tells us kind of the most powerful
narrative here, and something frankly we
didn't expect.
Is that the horizontal access here is just
days working on the site.
Vertical axis is just a count of the
number
of those modules that a student shows
proficiency in.
So each of those lines is essentially the
progression of a student in the class.
And what we're seeing in every class we're
working with.
We have Los Altos and Los Altos regular
class and Los
Altos remedial class and San Jose and e,
and east Palo Alto.
When you start a class.
Right at the beginning there's some kids
that race ahead,
some kids in the middle, and some kids
that are behind.
In a traditional model like, okay, these
are the kids
that are gonna be, you know, doctors,
engineers, lawyers, they're
gonna, you know, apply to Stanford and all
the rest,
these are average kids, these kids are the
remedial kids.
What we're seeing is if you allow students
to
work at their own pace, at their own time.
And you don't know who these students are.
It's really unpredictable.
We're, we're gonna try to fine tune the
analytics so we can predict this even
better.
If you give them a chance to, to build
their foundation.
Start from one plus one.
All of a sudden that student, and that
blue student is one of them.
Ten days into it slightly below average,
actually right out the gate rea,
reasonable bit below average, after 70
something days best student in the class.
And we're seeing it over and over again,
in every context.
That, after two, three, four months, the
best dude in the class is
often a kid that you thought was a
remedial student, two, three months ago.
And we're seeing it over and over and over
again.
And just to give you an ener-, a sense of
the energy of these classrooms.
Cuz sometimes, when you say, oh, computer
learning, blended learning.
People imagine kind of a Vulcan borg
reality of kind of, things plugged in.
Like, you know?
And kids just doing this all day.
And and, and and I, I, I wanna show you
this classroom,
and actually even this classroom, the, the
visuals aren't exactly, cuz whenever
the press tries to take it, they're like,
oh, this is what
the program is, so I wanna, we wanna film
kids doing the program.
We're like no, no.
What's cool about this, is, because this
is ten, 20, 30% of class time, it frees
up all this other time for peer to
peer tutoring, for project based learning,
whatever else.
But the media always wants to get the kids
actually on the computer.
So that will, there is that in this
footage,
but it does capture the energy level in
these classrooms.
>> From Mountain View California NBC's
Kristen Welker has our story tonight.
>> [SOUND] What makes fifth graders cheer?
Would you believe math?
>> I'm starting to really like math now.
>> These kids are learning with the help
of Kahn Academy, an online school.
>> You got it right.
Good job.
>> Videos.
That are interactive and fun, explaining
difficult concepts in a conversational
way.
>> And there's a fun story that came out
of that actual, when that reporter visited
that classroom.
She saw a little fifth grader working
on, on trigonometry, you know, normally
11th grade,
12th grade type material but she was
you know, she was [INAUDIBLE] sine,
cosine, tangent.
She understood the ratios of the triangle.
The reporter sits down next to her and
says so,
so, so do you thing this is fifth grade
math?
And the girl got a very mischievous grin
on her
face and she goes no, I think it's sixth
grade.
[LAUGH].
>> So you know the anecdotal stuff was
great, the teachers were happy, the
students were happy but, but there, you
know, we still have to measure it.
At least measure like you know like, make
sure harm isn't
being done here because you know there are
these state tests.
This is a public school.
We're not teaching to the test in the
videos.
I don't use necessarily the same words
that are gonna show up on the assessment.
There are kids in those classrooms that
are doing fourth grade
math, there's kids in those classrooms
doing tenth, 11th grade math
and how are they gonna perform on a fifth
grade assessment,
or in, in one of the [INAUDIBLE] a seventh
grade assessment?
And we were particularly worried about the
seventh graders.
The fifth graders was standard Los
Altos demographic, high performing school
district.
The seventh, the two seventh grade classes
that piloted it, these
were, it wasn't Los Altos, which is a,a
affluent school district.
But this was a remedial math class in Los
Altos.
And most of these students in this class,
were students who
were either diagnosed with learning
disabilities you know, a, dyslexia, ADHD.
And many of them were essentially from the
other side of El Camino.
They were par-, essentially part of the,
the parts of
Mountain View that were thrown into the
Los Altos School District.
So these, these were actually
traditionally.
Underperforming students.
And what was neat, is we saw that
narrative again.
And, and we were worried about this, cuz
we are like,
our product is new, we don't wanna be, you
know, blamed too.
You know, maybe they won't work with, with
this group of students.
But what was amazing for us, and frankly
for Los Altos the
district, is that this is where we saw of
the most profound gains.
So what we saw, 2010 were, was the
distribution of scores for this, for this
cohort.
Entering in, 23% were proficient.
And they were the low end of proficient.
That's why they were in this class.
47% were basic, 23% below basic, 6% far
below basic.
And then after six months, and this is
exciting,
the 6 plus 35, 41% were now proficient or
better.
And the whole curve it shift.
There were no longer any far below basic.
The whole distribution shifted in the
right direction.
But what was really neat and what we had
never
expected with, with [INAUDIBLE] is, this
was a remedial math class.
Some of these kids, diagnosed with
learning disabilities.
6% of these kids were now advanced.
6% of these kids had leapfrogged ahead of
students who were not placed in remedial
math class.
And there was no way, frankly, of
predicting who
they were until we frankly, we saw the
data.
And, you know, normally these classes are
kind of the, the graveyard
of your academic career, but it actually
was able to accelerate these students.
So the last thing I, I wanna share with
you
and, and I have a couple other slides if
all ask a question about them is, is is a
story we got this past summer which is
pretty exciting.
We get a lot of testimonials and letters
and if any of you
all have any, feel free to share it with
us it's, it's good for
company morale but, but I wanna show you
something because for us it
highlights how much potential there is out
in the world, human potential,
intellectual potential.
And, and how it can just be tapped into,
if you
just give people, just, just a little bit
of the right tools.
>> My name is Mark Halverstad.
Growing up I was really always a C
student.
I think I was really pretty much always
pretty pitiful in school.
I don't think I've ever gotten higher than
a B+ in any math class ever particularly.
I pretty much thought that the only thing
I was
good enough to do, in college, was major
in music.
And I went off and I got a music degree in
Saxophone.
But I, I sort of almost felt that it was
more,
I was getting it because I was terrible at
everything else.
And I worked as a saxophone player for a
few years.
Really what I wanted to do was.
Do electrical engineering.
And the last thing that I
remember completely not getting was trig
identities.
So, I went to YouTube and I did a search
for
trig identities, and Khan Academy was the
first thing that popped up.
Watched a bunch of videos in the trig
playlist to kinda get caught up to speed.
I watched all the videos in the calculus
playlist.
I watched all the videos in the physics
I watched a bunch of videos on dividing
decimals and even on a, subtraction by
borrowing.
I watched a lot of videos on, on
arithmetic.
That was in 2007 I did that Until the fall
of 2010 and in the fall of 2010 I
I took a leap and I decided to go go back
to school and went to Temple University.
Majored in electrical engineering getting
a second bachelors.
And keep in mind I, I, I don't think I've
ever
gotten about a B+ in math classes and I
was really.
A straight C student growing up.
And I just finished this year.
First year back in college.
I got a 4.0 GPA for the entire year.
I got perfect scores on both of my
calculus
final exams and also on my chemistry final
exams.
I ended.
calculus, Chemistry, both [UNKNOWN] and
chemistry
with an average higher than a 100%.
I, there are some kind of canny videos
that I probably listen to the same
concept over 20 or 30 times and there is
no tutor.
In the world I could have paid to have sat
next
to me and repeated the same thing over 20
or 30 times.
Without at least them getting a little bit
judgemental or at least them get,
thinking, oh
well, this guy really never is going to
get this concept and he should just give
up.
Where the understanding really happened
was.
Watching those videos.
And, and also working through the Khan
Academy software and everything.
The impact for me in my life, I, I really
see it, growing exponentially over the
next 20 or 30 years.
So from the bottom of my heart, thank you.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
[SOUND] Makes you feel good.
So I'd love I'd love to take I'd love to
take questions now.
I know there are some people who have to
leave at six o'clock, so feel free to
leave if
you have to leave, at six o'clock, but I'd
love
to take as, as many questions until they
get boring.
>> Thank you so much for, for joining us.
I'm Greg [UNKNOWN], an MBA and Masters of
Education dual degree student.
ACtually, taking a class on non-profits
and writing about Khan Academy.
We had to look at the mission statement.
And it's incredibly inspirational to
educate, you
know, free, world-class education to
anyone anywhere.
But when thinking about it and watching
the videos
and playing with it in the TED talk, a
lot of what gets me excited and has got
the media excited is the idea of blended
learning.
And so I was wondering, do you
see your mission pivoting at all?
Are you still focused on global education?
Cuz I think, sort of rural kids in Africa.
So, what, if you had another $2 million,
wh, what's next for you?
Where, where would you go with that
mission?
>> Yeah, no, so, so, I mean, this is, our,
our,
the most difficult thing right now as an
organization is that
we have an abundance of opportunity,
because there's like, okay, there's
the, you know, just the standard student
who just needs help.
Right, like this student right here.
You have the blended learning
opportunities, what's happening in Los
Altos.
And not just Los Altos we're seeing it at
Eastside Prep in Palo Alto.
At some of the charter schools [UNKNOWN].
There's the possibilities if you go into
rural Africa, or
rural India, go places where they don't
have teachers right now.
And all of sudden you can give them
something better
than maybe even, wha, what they would
otherwise have access to.
ou-, our, what, what.
The way we were thinking about it right
now,
is in the near term, let's continue to
focus
on these students, cuz out of the four
point
whatever million they're using their, this
is 95% of them.
And this is, we can reach it.
And we think that, that problem is 95% the
same problem as.
How do we, what can we do in a classroom?
If we can get someone, you know, education
is the spectrum of things.
I mean and we can debate for hours about
what it means.
But there's a general sense that at this
end, there's kind
of your core academic skills,
understanding what a derivative is,
learning
to apply algebra, understanding the
conceptual physics, and as you get
further and further here it becomes more
open ended and more broad.
You know, this is starting a company,
composing a sonata, painting a picture.
Something very open ended, and right now
most schools are very focused right over
here.
And what we're saying is we think this, we
can do this stuff pretty well with
the data and analytics and iterate over
the
content but, that doesn't mean we're
replacing schools.
That means it's an opportunity for schools
to move up this
progression, and as we get better and
better we're just gonna push
the envelope here and that the physical
environments can get better
and better, and our, the way we're
thinking of it strategically is.
We don't wanna try to do everything at
once, and just be a flash in the pan and.
We wanna prove that this is real, espe.
You know, we're gonna start in U.S.,
primarily
English, although we are transitioning
into ten other languages
right now, and then we'll explore, we're,
and,
and there are already, frankly, NGOs, I
mean we
heard there's people using it in rural
Mongo,
I think all of Mongolia is rural but, you
know, they're using this, they're,
they're, you know,
we heard some Burmese refugee camps were
using it.
So I mean, so it's, this stuff is already
happening.
We're putting it out there.
If someone wants a DVD.
Here's the DVD.
You wanna thumb drive with all the videos?
Here you go.
You want an offline copy?
Someone's Jerry-rigged, it to do that.
We're open in that way, but our
organizational focus right now is just to
really
make sure that it's a, it's a
substantive contribution to what happens
first, around us.
>> Thank you [INAUDIBLE]
>> Okay, yeah, yeah, right here.
>> I had two questions, actually.
One was you talk about capturing the
potential
of film and, you know talent out there.
So the obvious question is, there are a
lot more
students in the class than, than teachers
in, in that class.
So, how do you capture the peer-to-peer
learning?
because, you know, kids learn better from
other kids [CROSSTALK].
>> Yep, yep.
>> Than from adults.
>> Yeah.
>> The second question is Do you have any
plans in terms of
your strategy to break the, enmity of Of
this, these content you know?
The [UNKNOWN] textbooks.
[CROSSTALK].
>> Yeah.
>> Pythorgas's theory never change.
>> Yes.
>> And yet, there's copyrights on that.
>> Yeah.
And, there's really a copyright on Happy
Birthday.
[INAUDIBLE].
>> So, how do, how do you plan to address
that?
Because that is really what, what's
holding
education back, in my, in my humble
opinion.
>> Yeah.
So, the peer-to-peer, which I'm a.
Just, I mean, just my own personal
experience in
high school and whatever, I'm a big
believer in peer-to-peer.
I mean, I, I, I think you all are probably
experiencing a
lot of the learning is happening, the two
nights before an exam,
where there's significant peer-to-peer
activity mostly
academic go, going on And so,
what we're, I mean that's what's
interesting about us working with physical
classrooms.
You know, there's 10,000 classrooms based
on data
they're doing it in some shape or form.
We're directly working with 50 of them,
and, we have these notions
and we're, you know, but the, the teachers
have some pretty good ideas.
The students have some pretty neat ideas,
and
we're seeing what kind of things naturally
emerge.
And the neat thing is, is that, if you
kind of allow students to get self
directed, and they're all learning at
their own
pace, a lot of this stuff just organically
emerges.
If you don't tell, as long as you don't
tell
students, be quiet, put a finger on your
lip, listen.
If you just say, learn at your own pace,
and do what
you need to do to learn, a lot of this
peer-to-peer starts emerging.
Kids start just naturally going to the
whiteboard.
This is what I can tutor you in.
This is what we can help with, and/ or
this is what I need help in.
And what we should, what we're trying to
do, is we're trying to observe the best
practices.
And seeing if we can put that in the
system.
So, we saw students setting goals for
themselves on notecards, and then seeing
how
they [INAUDIBLE] so it's almost pulled out
as a feature, we saw students printing out
their achievements and showing it to other
friends, so it's like oh, we should
have public profiles, if you wanna share
it, you can share it with other people.
so, so what we're tying to do is if, if
we, we'll eventually hopefully
have a place where if you need help,
there's other people in the community.
Who can help you.
You can, you know have cloud, cloud tutors
that, at
any given point, someone has office hours
in that subject.
so, so we're going to explore all of that.
In terms of the, the textbook industry,
and, you know,
and I say this somewhat to protect my own
safety.
I don't think us by ourselves is a
catalyst but,
I think they're, they're facing a major
problem, because whether it's.
You look at, you know are there these kind
of transitional
solutions where people are doing free
books, open-source textbooks, you know.
I think, actually, they kind of signed
their death
certificate when they, you know, they did
this $15.
A textbook cannot cost most than $15 on an
iPad.
And, and, and there's no barriers to
distribution now, with
the, so that's gonna bring it's cost down
very quickly.
But I think it raises an even broader
question, what does a textbook do?
It does two things.
It tries to teach you some new concept.
And right now it's done in this very kind
of
cryptic prose, and then they give you some
practice problems.
And they give you the answer to every
other problem in the back of the book.
And so, we think, online video, especially
when you can track what's
being used, how effective it is, and all
the rest with analytics.
Is better than that prose, you can pause
and
repeat, you get human intonation, human
emotion, and we think
adaptive exercises where you get data and
analytics and instant
feedback, and hints, is better than the,
the stuff at
the back of the book, and if that's
available for
essentially free I guess this is a case
study in
an industry, soon to be collapsed, I guess
is yeah,
yeah, yeah, a quick one yeah, yeah I just
wanna.
Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE]
[INAUDIBLE] Yeah.
So, the question is.
Again, this is a very good question.
YouTube is a [INAUDIBLE] you know what?
Video by itself is a one-way stream.
And, and, and if someone uses it well, it
can be somewhat active.
You can pause and repeat, and you can say
oh, I need to go watch that now and I.
You can be a little self-directed about
it.
But [UNKNOWN] It is still a passive mode,
and so,
frankly, most of our resources are more on
the interactive side.
The videos are there to compliment it, but
we are also trying
to work on things where, the videos are
also, giving you questions.
And that, there's questions associated
with videos.
When you're reviewing, we can give you
those conceptual questions, and then
we can know, hey, maybe you should go
watch this video over there.
And the other thing that's happened, we
just seen this on YouTube, is.
Someone says oh, that was a good video, I
don't quite
understand what you meant by this, by
orthogonal at minute three.
And then someone else on YouTube says,
hey, you just need to
go watch this other video, where it's
defined a little bit more.
when, when the videos are granular, almost
every video is an answer to someone's
question.
And they somewhat, to some degree, just
have to be directed.
to, to that answer, and that's where the
community,
and we're, we're only just starting to, to
explore that.
Right over here?
>> Yeah, hi I'm [UNKNOWN] and I'm at the
GSP, and I'm from Bangladesh, and I
wanted to tell you that, people are mighty
proud of what you've done back home, so-.
>> Oh, yeah, no, it's surreal that they,
yeah, they.
>> So, um-.
>> I got a call from Muhammad, you know, I
was like Muhammad who?
>> [LAUGH] I was like-.
>> So so my question is you guys are
registered
as a non-profit, and a lot of people see
your biggest
potential as being virtual school or sort
of spreading the
reach of education to impoverished
communities in Africa and Asia, so.
But how do you see the fact that
you're operating on a non-commercial
platform, reducing your scalability?
>> Yeah, so that's a very good question
and, you know, it's a question you
get in Silicon Valley a lot, that you
know, a not for profit doesn't scale.
That, you know, how are you gonna get the
capital, how
are you gonna track the talent, you know,
all of these questions.
And, and, and in, in my end, I think it,
it, it's
worth kind of clarifying just, you know,
what a not for profit is.
Not for profit essentially means no one
owns it.
The capital structure, there's no owner.
It's owned by society.
It can, in theory, I mean, our mission is
to actually give the
content away for free, but you know,
Stanford is a not for profit.
You can [INAUDIBLE] they can generate
revenue.
What a not for profit says, is all
of that revenue, gets re-invested into the
business.
It gets reinvested in the mission.
While in a for profit, some gets
reinvested in the mission, and some
of it can get dividended out or stock
[INAUDIBLE] or, or whatever else.
So, it's, it's, it's a fundamental, it's a
capital structure thing.
In terms of the access to capital I mean,
it's a huge space,
I mean, just think about public
education's like a trillion dollars a
year.
You think about how much the Gates
foundation alone spent
almost a billion dollars a year in the
U.S., so
the, there, there are, there are people,
philanthropists, many people
in Silicon Valley who got the capital, so
I want.
This is what they care about.
They want to invest in education,
especially if there's a high social
return.
And, any way you're on our spreadsheets,
you know, our
total invested capital to date, is less
than $3 million.
And we're reaching four and a half million
students per month.
This time next year it might be 20
million, three years it might be 100
million students.
And, the content's not going [INAUDIBLE]
we can only improve on it.
So it's, it's an infinite, social return.
The other question, this was a question
that we
actually took very seriously is, can we
attract the talent?
You know, there's no lottery ticket at the
Khan Academy.
You're, you're working here.
There's not a stock option that you can,
you can become a billionaire.
We, we do try to pay very competitive
salaries in Silicon Valley.
But it's like.
Can we attract the best talent?
And it, it was an open question, I would
say about six months ago.
But what we've seen in the past, actually
we saw this before the first, we've
seen this throughout, is not only can we
attract good talent, we're attracting the
best talent.
I don't know if you all saw the press
release.
The number one employer, Google, just
joined us.
And, I mean, you know, I guess you can
afford to do what do what, what he
likes [LAUGH] but, but we're getting,
we're getting
the best talent, even people who aren't
independently wealthy.
I mean our, our lead engineer, Ben Kamens,
who
was the head engineer Fog Creek Software,
Joel on Software.
Our lead designer, the head designer
there,
we got the head of high frequency trading
from one of the top hedge funds in the
world, as our head of analytics.
We are getting [UNKNOWN] who is our
president, was about to make partner at
Mackenzie.
I mean, these are the, the, the, the best
talent out there, and
what, what you realize, is there's
actually
been psychological studies on this, is
that.
People are happiest, and are the most
productive, and you will get the best
talent.
You take money of the table.
You do have to pay enough, that they can
live, they can get
a mortgage, they can buy their Honda
Accord, and all, all the rest.
But you take that off the table.
You don't have to pay millions, you just
have to to pay
a good, i would say upper middle class
salary, in Silicon Valley.
And if you get, if do that, if you'd have
intellectually satisfying work.
And they have a mission to pursue, they'll
be the
most productive people on the planet, and
we're actually seeing that.
The people that we're, the resumes that
we're getting, the, the, the energy
level in the company, it's better than any
hedge fund we've worked at,
it's better than any management consulting
firm that many of our teams have
worked at, it's just, it's, it's, it's,
it's kind of been an unbelievable
experience.
So we're, we're feeling pretty good about.
You know, we're in uncharted waters.
There's only a few, I would say highly
scalable not for profits out there.
You know, Wikipedia's kind of in that
space.
Kiva's in that space.
We're in there.
Mozilla foundation.
We're all kind of in there.
We're all a little bit different.
But I think, we are facing, there's an
inflection point in society where there's
a space, for these type of, I would call
them new institutions to emerge.
>> Hi, I'd like to ask a question about a
phrase you used that's near
and dear to my heart, because I taught the
subject for 12 years in high school.
How many people here are familiar with
project based learning?
You've heard, yeah, okay, good, good.
Theodore Sizer, Brown University
basically, this is a nutshell description.
Students go in depth into a subject, but
showing what they understand about science
and math.
As it is applied to a real world
situation, and since
you mentioned that phrase, I was just
wondering what you might be
doing about developing it as one, an
adjunct for students that, who
turn around, learn a subject, and then
teach it to others, through.
>> Absolutely, so, right now, I think, you
know, the whole education debate is
actually slightly distorted.
You have one camp, where they say
oh, we need more open-ended, project based
learning.
And then you have another camp saying oh,
well if you do that, our kids aren't
gonna do well on the SAT, and they're not
gonna do well on the state exams.
We have to do more traditional, academic,
a lot
of problem solving, a lot of traditional
types of problems.
And I think there's two issues.
I think one on the project based learning
side.
Projects in and of themselves, there's a
huge spectrum of what they can be.
In one spectrum, they can be very cookie
cutter, paint by numbers, you know, kind
of stuff that a lot of us might have done
in, in elementary school, whatever.
And, and, and the other spectrum, they can
be hugely open ended.
The could be you know, starting a
business,
painting a picture, building a robot,
inventing something, whatever.
And, and so, what we see as our role is.
Our role is, I, I think a lot of what I've
described, we can be a catalyst for
freeing up physical human time.
And we think the best use of
that is broadly described as project based
learning.
But what we are seeing is, now that you
free up this time, it's actually becoming.
Some teachers, immediately they say oh,
this, there's things that I've always
wanted to do with this time, and I can now
do it.
But there's a lot of teachers saying wow
this is kinda scary.
What do I do with this extra time now in
the classroom?
And, and so, we're, we're exploring that.
And, and, and what we're saying is, it
shouldn't even be one class anymore.
Let's explore the boundaries.
When every student learns at their own
pace.
Why,why group them by age group?
Why separate calculus from physics, from
art, from history, from statistics?
Have them all happening at the same time.
Why have a bell ring every 55 minutes?
Why be afraid to go deep in a subject,
because you're going to miss class?
All of these things shouldn't be questions
anymore.
And so, we're, we're pushing the envelope
with as many existing schools as possible.
There's this school in Los Angeles, the
Marlboro School, Marlboro Academy.
That is actually doing that.
They have seven to 12th grade girls, all
in the same class.
All in the same class.
Teaching each other, going back to the
peer-to-peer, peer learning.
And, and, so far, it seems to be pretty
profound.
Next year they're gonna double the number
of students,and they are
gonna double the number of teachers, but
the teachers are going
to be in the same room together, which is
also something
that's kind of unheard of in, in a
traditional academic model.
And, we are bringing people on.
We're running in, a summer camp this
summer, to
explore, what can you do with a physical
environment?
Like that risk game that I talked about,
where kids are, you
know, they're learning what a market is,
and probability and all that.
What can you do in a physical environment?
Building robots, starting businesses,
whatever else.
And so, what we wanna do is see the best
practises, document them.
If we can make tools for them, so they
can happily use in a classroom, we wanna
build them.
Or at minimum, document them so that other
teachers
can, can mimic them any, anywhere in the
world.
>> Thanks for being here.
I just wanted to know, what's your
curriculum ideology,
if there's any ideology behind your what
you're doing?
And what, as you have studied doing,
having
doing these videos, what do you think that
you're doing better than say, traditional
teachers in
the classroom, that makes kids get it
faster?
>> Yeah, so the ideology question.
This is something I like to stress.
I don't think there's one thing I said
here,
that's kind of new, in terms of an idea.
I mean, the more that I talk to people,
the more that
I, I realize wow, someone, someone's been
writing about this 100 years ago.
Someone's been writing, and there's even
been
studies that people said, wow this really
worked.
And for some reason it gets lost.
So, I dont know exactly what ide, ideology
would be called.
I mean, I mean there, you know.
it, and it's very scary when you label
things, because then
there's people in the other camp, who
immediately try to, you know.
If you say that you are constructivist,
and they're like, oh constructivism.
Where we need to be.
But I would say it is a combination of
master
based learning, so this idea that you
should learn things, well.
You don't have to be the absolute
expert on exponents before you do basic
equations.
But you should have a solid foundation, so
that you don't get tripped up later.
I, I would say, highly influenced by
constructivist thinking,
that you really do learn well, when you
explore things.
But at the same time, you have to relax
the
tension that the world is assessing you
based on these exams.
And so, we think, hopefully we can, we can
help do both at the same.
I think, you know, there's kind of
self-paced learning
peer-to-peer learning, I mean, whatever
you wanna call it.
But, I mean, we're just trying to do what
kinda makes, be practical
about it, not, not be too dogmatic about
one, one or the other.
In terms of, in terms of, in terms of,
kind of, why the videos
have resignated with people it's an open
question, I mean, people comment on it.
I think there's been a couple things.
I think it was really important that I
started off making them for my cousins.
I think if in 2006, Bill Gates kind
of descended, and, and, and, and said Sal
here
is x million dollars, make some videos
that
will are gonna reach hundred of millions
of people.
I probably would have made things not too
different
from what you get on a DVD from McGraw
Hill.
I probably would've made these very fancy
computer graphics, and those, the
next stage in photosynthesis, you know, it
sound like your GPS device.
[LAUGH] And, and, and.
And, and, and, the reason why those look
that way, is because when a decision
maker, superintendent,
or even sometimes the teacher,so when
anyone looks at
it for 30 seconds they're like, oh, that's
professional.
That looks cool.
That's using computer graphics.
And the decision makers are never actually
sitting
down and asking, am I actually learning
photosynthesis
here, am I actually understanding
photosynthesis, do I
actually feel a human connection, with
this person?
And, I think what was neat, early on for
me is, I was like.
It was, it was a human to human.
Even today when people watch the videos,
they feel
like I'm, I'm, you know, I'm their older
brother.
I'm their neighbor.
You don't see my face.
Faces are, are high distracting,
especially when they have a unibrow.
And, and so, [LAUGH] and, and, so, you
take that out so it really feels,
it really feels like, or an Indian
Ray Romano, I've sometimes been referred
to [LAUGH].
But, but, but, it, it really feels like
we're
sitting next to each other at the kitchen
table.
The focus is on the content, you know.
The, the voice is, is kinda of there I
mean, I've
actually gotten letters from people
saying, you know, when they normally think
they think in their own voice, but as soon
as they
see an equation, they start hearing, well,
let's think about this now.
>> [LAUGH]
>> They hear this, you know, so I don't, I
don't know.
I think it's the conversationality of it.
It feels human.
It feels, you know, I think a lot of
education material is made very top down.
The, you know, some group, some politician
or executive
says we need to make content in this area.
Then they go hire a bunch of experts and
I'm
not being disparaging of the experts, but
when you have
a crowd doing it together, they have
fights on what
the content should be, they should write,
they'll write scripts.
And at the end they go and find some
teacher or somebody,
some and they pay them by the hour to
essentially read their script.
And that whole process is saying the least
important thing in this process
is the actual content, and what we're
saying are the most important thing is.
Even, you know, I'm the executive director
of the [UNKNOWN] but I still spend at
least 50% of my time making content
because that's what's going to resonate
with students.
We put a high priority on our developers
that are making actual content that
students are using.
We're not, we're not just all
oh, strategy's everything, platform is
everything.
The content is what actually, that's where
the rubber hits the road.
>> Hi.
I'm an undergrad here at Stanford and, I
was fortunate enough to attend
Montessori School for until 7th grade, and
one of the strengths I see
of Montessori School is, kind of exactly
what you're doing in letting people
go at their own pace so in 2nd grade I was
already starting algebra.
And I could be at a totally different
level in reading and so I'm wondering.
>> Do you have like four PhD's now?
[LAUGH].
>> And so I'm wondering to what extent
you've looked at existing models like
Montessori it's kind of like what his
question was and to what extent you're
maybe working with Montessori schools to
kind
of make Montessori scalable when it's been
criticized as something that can only work
in small schools where teachers are highly
paid.
>> Yeah, you know, and I'm not an expert
here, I
mean you know, like a lot of people I
always thought Montessori
was something that goes through you know,
pre-k and maybe kindergarten
and I've only started learning about
Montessori programs that go much deeper.
And we've actually just been reached out
by Montessori,
I think their K through 12 on the east
bay.
And I think they hear a lot of what we're
saying and wait that's
what we've been doing forever that's what
you know, that's what Montessori is about.
Self paced learning kids teaching kids
kids experimenting
with things and yeah we're here to kinda
of.
And you know, we have a long way to go.
We think we're in the beginning of the
first inning.
But, a lot of what we're talking about
actually is maybe the missing link in
Montessori.
Is that yes, a self paced learning all of
that but
how does the, how do we know that you're
learning things?
Or how can we, [UNKNOWN] you know, how
does,
how does a teacher have data to intervene
properly?
Or how does the student know they're
learning properly and things like that.
And so, there's a certain level of you can
have a scaffold of, kind of, this type
of self based learning that I think makes
people more comfortable with the really
open ended stuff.
So yeah, I think they're one and the
same very, very, very complimentary.
>> How do you, given that, so.
In creating the content for Kahn Academy,
you focus on economic subjects like math.
Here, we'll teach you math in extremely
granular patterns,
or we'll teach you biology or chemistry or
whatever.
So why couldn't you extend this to nearly
any other form of human learning?
>> Yeah.
I don't want to, like,.
Think of like, I don't like, I don't want
to, like
imagine Kahn Academy as like some self
help course.
But why couldn't Kahn Academy have a
course in procrastination?
>> Oh, yeah.
[LAUGH].
>> Or social skills, [CROSSTALK] since you
have so many of them.
>> Well no, and I, I have a, my daughter
and, my
daughter is now seven months old, my son
is three years old.
And I've been thinking, because, you know,
right
now I'm not that far from the dating
world.
I mean, you know, I'm still pretty far,
I'm, but, but, you know, if I give her,
them advice now and we time shift, [LAUGH]
so
I give like, dating advice, they'll take
it more.
So I you might see that type of stuff
[LAUGH] on, on, on Khan Academy.
But, but, but, but what that said, you
know, we
actually, I don't know if the, there's a
presentation still up.
>> You want me to, yeah.
>> The, presentation is still up,
[INAUDIBLE] the next life
we're actually exp, we, we've started some
experiments with, with
the Stanford Med School, and actually have
some videos of
some of the stuff that we, we, we were
playing with.
I mean, it's just Purely experimentation.
>> There you go.
>> But, what we really want to experiment,
what we really wanna do.
And I'll show you these videos 'cuz
they're kinda of fun.
I mean these were just kinda just, we just
tried it out.
I just hung out at the med school.
>> And so there is a problem right there
at that junction.
>> So at least that part of drug kinetics
we
need to understand how they penetrate
different parts of the body.
>> if we can get to those patients and get
them to skilled health care.
Both in the field and at the hospital.
We can affect their outcomes and, and what
the, the lamina connects to the spinous
process.
>> Remember this is a drug that didn't
even touch the breast cancer.
Had a dramatic effect in the survival of
these young women.
>> Right.
>> And so again it just makes this a whole
new way in thinking about disease.
>> Yea, so, what we're hoping to do over
there, and you're
gonna see it hopefully over the next year
is, you know, I
started with a lot of content, we started
building this platform, analytics,
and all the rest, we're like, hey, that
can be used by anybody.
And so hopefully over the next year you're
gonna start seeing other, possibly major
institutions saying
hey, we can start offering courses on this
platform, leveraging it in any shape and
form.
So I would love, I mean i don't know, how
many of y'all read Diamond Age?
Niel Stevenson?
So yeah, I would love this to be the young
ladies illustrated primer where.
>> [LAUGH].
>> The book is essentially NEO Victorian
China you know, it's highly, highly
hierarchical society.
This is like you know, in the future.
this, this nobleman wants to essentially
get this engineer
to build like the ultimate learning
platform for his granddaughter.
The, the, the engineer thinks it's so good
that he builds a version for his own
daughter.
And it being China, gets bootlegged
[LAUGH].
And and, and then it gets in the hands of
two thousand orphan girls and they take
over the planet.
>> > [LAUGH].
>> So, yes, that, that'd be a good
outcome.
Yeah.
>> And we should probably go for two more
questions.
>> Yes, sounds good.
>> Three more, just so we can end and get
you to your next commitments.
>> Yes.
Two more questions.
Better be good.
>> Thank you for speaking today so I'm
actually a
first-year medical student and I
recognized Dr. Perber's voice on there.
>> Oh yes.
>> And I'm meeting with some teachers from
the Children's Hospital school tomorrow at
Lucille Packard
to see how Khan Academy can be
implemented,
1 because they are at times under staffed,
and 2, it might be interesting to assess
the cognitive effects of certain
treatments downstream, so
what, I guess, guidelines, or even
cautionary notes
would you provide to people who are
looking to.
Implement Khan Academy in new settings.
But perhaps, you know, in a somewhat
experimental way.
>> Yeah, no, we think it's great.
I mean, we think it's great.
I mean, that's, that's a fun thing about
it.
You put it out there.
And people are figuring out, I mean,
that's actually
an example that we've heard, that people
are, you know,
with children with these, with these kinda
chronic diseases
that are in the hospital for months at a
time.
They can learn now we've, we've heard
of, actually like child athletes and
actors using
this because, once again, they're We
actually heard
about prisoners I mean, there, there a
captive
audience I mean, it's, it's a- [LAUGH]
but, but, it, it, it's, yeah, yeah, I
mean, I would say do it.If you hit
road bumps, and it should be relatively
self-service.
We're trying to make it more self-service
every day.
But ping us you know, I'm
skhan@khanacademy.org.
You can look at our, at our, our website.
Emails, if you have any questions.
Cuz our goal is just to make it as
self-service as, as possible.
>> Thank you.
>> One more question.
>> Alright so, hypothetically, if someone
were
thinking about starting a company in the
ed
tech space that built off of, built on top
of, but didn't compete with Khan Academy.
>> Oh, there's nothing wrong with
competition.
>> No, no, no, sorry.
That's, that's not exactly my question.
so, there seems to be, rhetorically, a lot
of excitement around the potential for,
for individuals, to learn from Khan
Academy
and become more confident in their skills.
But in your talk what I saw a lot of
excitement from you
about was your partnership with schools,
Los Altos schools and also the schools of
medicine here, so I would say, I would
ask, for your vision for
Khan Academy, let's say over the next five
to 10 years to be realized.
Who do you think are gonna be some of your
key partners generally speaking?
And what role do they have to play in
kinda of the larger educational space
in order for Khan to really have the
impact that you want it to have?
>> Yeah, no and I mean, I'll, my answer
will
probably change every week to, to this,
but the general notion.
I mean, I think, going into this class, I
think the content providers, I mean.
One of the fun things for me about this
job is I, I get
to hopefully kind of spend the rest of my
life learning and teaching things.
I mean, I'm already kinda of, you know,
and, and that's a
fun thing to do, but I, there's no way I
can teach.
Everything or even a fraction of
everything and so I
think, I think catalyzing other people
like Doctor Prober and other,
you know, experts to one, be willing to do
this which
I think they are and also feel comfortable
in this type.
You know, not the traditional lecture but
the more
conversational style maybe two people at
the same time.
So I think the content creators, I think,
and that's not just video.
It could be exercise content it could be
static questions.
We're hoping to experiment with maybe
crowd sourcing of questions.
I mean it's crazy that every teacher in
the country has a different set of
questions.
And if they want comments then they have
to go pay someone money.
They should just be able to pool it, there
should be analytics on it, they
should be able to create you know, kids
going to the computer lab and say give
me a test where every kid's gonna get
different questions but they're
statistically the same and
the distribution looks like this and
there's only
a 5% chance that one kid doesn't finish.
And bam, it just happens.
That should exist.
I mean, there's nothing scientifically
implausible about that.
so, so, I think, it, it's kinda of the
community is what we're going to have to
leverage.
In terms of, in terms of kind of the key
partners, I think there's an interesting,
I, I think the major
institutions that, to some degree research
institutions that we are,
we're hoping [UNKNOWN] kinda turns into a
platform for cognitive education.
Whatever type of research.
I mean, you know, you have 2 million kids
doing problems every day.
I mean, that might be 2, mill, 20 million
problems done every day.
You could, if you have a better you know,
and idea of how, a better way for
people to conceptualize fractions and you
have a
way of measuring it, we already doing AB
testing.
We put 5% of the audience in front of that
versus the control.
See what, one day you have your data for
your PhD.
You, I mean, it sounds crazy.
Oh you are doing it.
Well you can come by, no.
We actually have a post [LAUGH] guy from
Stanford who is
about to come on board to, to do research
on our data.
So I think the research institutions.
I think, I think there's a very
interesting
potential, obviously from a content point
of view.
With Stanford, the MIT's of, of the world.
I think, the really forward thinking, its
the, I would say, schools of any.
You know, age or demographic, you know.
Whether it's Marlborough, which is an
elite girls' school in
Los Angeles or East Side Prep, which is a
highly
effective charter school, actually they're
an independent school, but they're,
they cater to an underserved demographic
in east Palo Alto.
I think those are gonna be key.
I think and I think it'll be interesting,
I think employers will be key, too.
Cuz I think, I think at the end of the
day, all of this, I mean,
the end goal, you know, people sometimes
confuse,
the end goal is happy and productive
people.
That's the angle.
And, I guess, a thriving democracy, run by
happy productive people.
[LAUGH] That's the angle.
And, so I think a lot of it is, well let's
just
cut to the chase, how do we get to that
angle, and
a lot of employers play a big role of
that, how do
we, and so, you know, everything we've
talked about is the learning side.
But I think there's, and we could talk for
another hour about it,
I put some videos on there if you all are
curious about it.
But I think there's a whole other
dimension of education which is the
credentialing side.
And I think, what we're in the process of
seeing
is that the two things are going to get
decoupled,
which will be a very good thing because it
kinda
of liberates the learning to happen in
whatever way's best.
And then the credentials become stronger
signals
because they're, you know, you, you, you
guys
Stanford, everyone, you're gonna anywhere
in the planet
and people are gonna know, oh Stanford,
yes.
You get an interview.
But 99% of universities in the world you
spend
the money, you take the time, you go
there.
Even if you learn the stuff tremendously,
you go to the next day the
next city and much less the next country
if you're like what is this?
I don't understand what this is.
And so I think the credentials could
become
even more powerful kind of more recognized
things.
And as that happens I think you're gonna
see a lot of Interesting dynamics in, in
education.
>> So, we should probably honour our
commitment with you that
you get home and have some time with your
own family.
>> Yes.
>> After spending time with us.
We do have a small gift for you knowing
that you graduated from Havard
Business School, we wanted you to have a
taste of the Stanford Business School.
>> Oh, yes, yes.
>> So we have autographed books by Jeff F
Fort, Chip Keith and Jennifer Aaker.
>> Oh, very good, Oh, thank you.
>> And the requisite.
Stanford swag.
>> [NOISE].
>> Oh, very good, thank you very much.
>> Thank you so much for doing this.
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
[NOISE].
>> You are a great guy.
>> Oh, well, thank you.
[NOISE]